Trascrizione: Martina Tortorici
Revisore: Anna Cristiana Minoli
Chiudete gli occhi.
E pensate ad una persona che ha fatto
delle grandi scoperte scientifiche.
Ce l’avete in mente?
Ok, riapriteli.
Quanti di voi hanno pensato
ad uno di loro?
Alzate la mano.
Ok, va bene,
ma quanti hanno pensato ad Einstein?
Eccovi.
Quanti di voi, invece,
hanno pensato ad una di loro?
Decisamente meno mani.
Sono Corinna.
Sono una scienziata.
E non sono Einstein.
Il mio primo esperimento l'ho fatto
quando avevo all'incirca 8 anni.
Non mi convinceva il fatto
che la scrittura di Babbo Natale
fosse molto simile a quella della Befana.
Così, un giorno, decisi di venirne a capo.
Prensi un foglio e scrissi:
“Caro Babbo Natale, se tu esisti,
domani questa lettera non ci sarà più.”
Piegai il foglio in quattro
e lo misi nella finestra.
Andai a dormire,
senza dire niente a nessuno.
Il giorno dopo mi svegliai
e, tutta contenta,
corsi alla finestra, la aprii..
e la lettera era ancora lì.
Così, alla fine, trassi le conclusioni
del mio esperimento
e per un bel po’ rimasi convinta del fatto
che Babbo Natale non esistesse,
ma la Befana sì.
A quel tempo passavo la mia giornata
tra la scuola e la palestra,
dove mi allenavo.
Facevo ginnastica.
Se mi chiedevano
cosa volessi fare da grande,
avevo già un sacco di idee:
l’atleta olimpionica,
la ginnasta olimpionica;
la trapezista del circo;
oppure l'astronauta.
Poi, crescendo, capii
che forse non sarei andata alle Olimpiadi,
né tantomeno nello spazio.
Ma continuarono
a regalarmi telescopi.
E così alla fine mi iscrissi a ingegneria.
Dopo qualche anno, dovetti decidere
dove fare la mia tesi di laurea
e ci provai.
Feci domanda al CERN,
il più grande laboratorio
di fisica delle particelle.
E mi accettarono.
Così partii, mi trasferii a Ginevra.
I primi mesi mi sentivo
come dentro a un frullatore.
Non parlavo una parola di francese
e passavo la mia giornata
in mezzo a scienziati di tutto il mondo
con storie e background
completamente diversi.
Avevo veramente la sensazione
che stessimo facendo qualcosa di grande.
Così mi ci volle ben poco
per innamorarmi della ricerca
e decisi di continuare
facendo un dottorato in fisica
che mi portò a lavorare e a vivere
tra la Svizzera e la Finlandia.
E così alla fine capii
che forse, da grande,
volevo fare la scienziata.
Quando racconto quello
che faccio alle persone,
di solito sono sorprese,
non se lo aspettano.
E principalmente ricevo
due tipi di reazioni.
La prima suona più o meno così:
“Fisica?! Mamma mia, che roba da nerd!
Non potevi fare qualcosa più da donna?”
La seconda:
“Fisica?! Oh mio Dio, è difficilissima!
Io non ci capivo niente a scuola.
Non ti chiedo quello che fai
perché tanto non lo capirei.”
Anche io a volte non lo capisco, comunque.
Ecco, mi sono resa conto
che viviamo in un mondo,
dove sembra che tra la scienza
e la vita di tutti i giorni
ci sia una distanza incolmabile.
Oggi, insieme a voi,
vorrei cercare di capire il perché
e provare a convincervi del contrario,
perché penso che essere
un pochino più inclusivi verso la scienza
fin dai primi anni dell’infanzia
possa aiutarci a crescere
degli adulti più preparati,
più consapevoli,
e quindi a crescere come società.
Innanzitutto, se ci pensate,
siamo stati tutti scienziati
nella nostra vita.
Quando eravamo piccolini,
che muovevamo i primi passi nel mondo,
esploravamo,
volevamo capire come funzionavano le cose
e facevamo tante domande.
Ecco, questa curiosità
e questo desiderio di conoscenza
sono anche alla base delle scienze.
Tuttavia, però, poi talvolta i bambini,
crescendo, sono esposti
ad una serie di fattori deterrenti,
a casa o a scuola,
che fanno sì che questa curiosità
vada un po’ a scemare.
Il primo fattore deterrente riguarda
il 50 per cento della popolazione
ed è un fattore di genere.
Infatti, bambini e bambine
non sono stimolati allo stesso modo
verso le materie STEM,
che sono tutte quelle materie
che includono
le scienze, la tecnologia,
l’ingegneria e la matematica.
L’idea che le bambine siano meno portate
alle materie scientifiche
è uno degli stereotipi
più difficili da sradicare.
Diversi studi hanno evidenziato
come questo sia
effettivamente un problema.
Infatti si è visto che, mediamente,
le bambine ottengono risultati più bassi
dei bambini nei test di matematica.
E se alcuni scienziati, pochissimi,
e personaggi pubblici hanno cercato
di dare delle spiegazioni biologiche
a questa cosa di genere,
la maggior parte
della comunità scientifica, invece,
ha lavorato per dimostrare il contrario,
cioè che queste differenze
non sono dovute a fattori biologici
perché bambini e bambine hanno
le stesse capacità cognitive,
cioè il loro cervello
davanti a un problema matematico
funziona allo stesso modo.
Ma anzi, queste differenze sono dovute
a fattori socio-culturali.
Vi faccio alcuni esempi.
Tra i 4 e i 7 anni,
i bambini hanno maggiori capacità spaziali
delle bambine.
I genitori, però, hanno anche riportato
di passare più tempo a giocare
con le costruzioni con i loro figli,
piuttosto che con le loro figlie.
E si sa, è provato,
che questo tipo di giocattoli aiuta
a sviluppare una serie di capacità,
come quelle spaziali,
o di problem solving,
o concetti di simmetria.
Vi basterà, quindi, fare un giro
per il reparto giocattoli del supermercato
per capire come già le bambine
partono svantaggiate in questo.
La buona notizia, però,
perché c’è una buona notizia,
è che nei paesi
con una maggior parità di genere
questa differenza nei risultati
di matematica va ad assottigliarsi
fino a scomparire.
Uno studio presentato da un gruppo
di ricercatori italiani ha considerato
40 paesi diversi, per un totale
di 270 mila ragazzi di 15 anni,
e si è visto...
hanno stilato una classifica
e si è visto che, sul podio,
non ci stupirà magari sapere
che troviamo i Paesi del Nord Europa,
con Norvegia e Svezia,
dove bambini e bambine
ottengono risultati equiparabili.
L’Islanda primeggia,
dove le bambine ottengono
risultati più alti.
In fondo alla classifica abbiamo
Turchia e Corea del Sud.
E l’Italia?
Secondo voi, dove si posiziona l’Italia?
Nella metà più bassa della classifica,
ad evidenziare quanto
questo ancora sia un problema
all’interno della nostra società.
Un secondo fattore deterrente
magari potrebbe risultare
un pochino più familiare a qualcuno di voi
ed è la fobia che si viene a creare
verso alcune materie scolastiche.
Nel mio caso era il latino,
ma molto spesso sono materie scientifiche.
Infatti, ci sembrano materie astratte,
poco applicative,
lontane dalla vita di tutti i giorni.
Quante volte ci siamo chiesti:
“a me questa roba qua cosa mi servirà?“
E così se queste materie vengono insegnate
solamente sui libri,
tralasciando tutta la parte sperimentale,
si perde tutto il processo creativo
e di immaginazione.
Così magari
impariamo dei concetti di ottica,
ma non prendiamo mai in mano
una macchina fotografica.
Oppure studiamo la chimica,
ma non sappiamo leggere le etichette
dei cibi che compriamo.
Se ci si focalizza solamente sulle regole,
è come se volessimo insegnare la musica,
ma solo in teoria,
senza mai suonarne una nota.
Non ci stupirà, quindi, poi
che queste materie ci sembrano
noiose,
difficili,
spaventose.
Quindi, abbiamo detto, la concomitanza
di questi due fattori deterrenti,
da una parte i fattori socio-culturali,
dall’altra la fobia che si può venire
a creare verso alcune materie,
fanno sì che a volte
i bambini perdano un po’ interesse
verso quella materia,
si impegnino meno,
ottengano risultati più bassi,
quindi pensino di non esserne capaci
e si impegnino ancora meno.
E questo va ad alimentare un loop,
è una concezione di se stessi
e delle proprie capacità
che poi difficilmente si riesce a colmare
durante l’adolescenza o l’età adulta.
E così,
solo pochi continuano poi ad informarsi,
a leggere articoli
di divulgazione scientifica.
La maggior parte delle persone, invece,
reduce dai ricordi scolastici,
appena sentono parlare di scienza
si terrorizzano e scappano.
Magari vi siete ritrovati
in quello che ho detto.
E magari poi, crescendo,
diventando adulti,
vi è anche capitato
di sentirvi disorientati
davanti alle domande dei bambini.
Le stesse che facevate voi
quando eravate piccoli.
Esistono gli alieni?
Come fanno le stelle a stare in cielo?
Perché il mare è blu?
Ecco, se vi è successo, magari
vi consolerà sapere che non siete soli.
Infatti, nel Regno Unito
hanno intervistato circa 2000 genitori
e hanno visto che
due terzi di loro non sa rispondere
alle domande di scienza dei loro figli.
E di questi, se un 25 per cento
cerca la risposta online,
un altro 20 per cento,
pur di togliersi da quella situazione,
dice che nessuno lo sa.
Oppure si inventa una risposta.
Ecco.
Magari no.
Va benissimo che i genitori non abbiano
le risposte alle domande dei loro figli.
Infatti, le possono cercare insieme.
Fare scienza non significa
avere le risposte a tutte le domande,
ma semplicemente
sapersi porre le domande nel modo giusto.
Come?
Con il pensiero scientifico.
Questo è composto
da una serie di passaggi.
Tutto parte da un’osservazione,
ci facciamo una domanda
che ci sembra interessante:
perché il mare è blu?
Perché la scrittura di Babbo Natale
e della Befana sono le stesse?
Dopodiché quello che il nostro cervello fa
è sviluppare un’ipotesi,
cioè costruiamo una teoria
per rispondere alla nostra domanda:
ok, uno dei due probabilmente non esiste.
Ma gli scienziati non si accontentano
di fermarsi qui.
Vogliono sapere
se la loro ipotesi è vera o no,
e quindi fanno una predizione.
Dicono: se la mia ipotesi è vera,
allora vedrò anche questa cosa qua.
Domani la lettera non ci sarà più.
Sviluppano un esperimento,
raccolgono i dati
e traggono le conclusioni.
Talvolta le conclusioni
ci portano al fatto
che la nostra ipotesi sia vera,
ma molto spesso non è così...
Quasi sempre.
Tipo il mio caso.
Tuttavia però, la ricerca
di prove scientifiche
è un’attività estremamente difficile
ed innaturale.
Infatti, l’evoluzione non ci ha modellati
per ricercare la verità
perché l’appartenenza ad una tribù
ha molto più valore
rispetto all’accuratezza oggettiva.
È molto più facile trarre conclusioni
basate su opinioni personali,
bias culturali,
o ripetere quello che sentiamo dire,
piuttosto che sui fatti e le osservazioni.
Ma forse ognuno dovrebbe chiedersi:
è proprio quello che voglio?
Allenare il pensiero scientifico
può aiutarci
ad invertire questa tendenza.
Non accontentarci
di sviluppare un’ipotesi,
ma voler sapere se questa è vera o falsa
ci aiuta a distinguere
tra ciò che è vero e falso.
Aumenta la criticità verso le nostre idee.
Tutto bello, direte voi.
Mi hai convinta.
Però a me ’sta roba cosa mi serve?
Tanto quanto gli integrali
che imparavo a scuola.
E invece no.
Questo non è utile
solamente a fisici o ingegneri,
ma può essere utile a tutti
nella vita di tutti i giorni.
Infatti, ci può aiutare
a saper riconoscere le trappole,
ad orientarci meglio
rispetto a quello che leggiamo online.
Pensate alle fake news.
Ma anche a diventare
dei cittadini più consapevoli
e vi spiego perché.
Viviamo in una società che è frenetica
ed in continua evoluzione.
Il bagaglio scientifico e tecnologico
raddoppia ogni 15-20 anni
e questo continuerà per tutto il secolo.
Pensate a com’era la nostra vita
vent’anni fa,
quando non esistevano gli smartphone,
non c’erano i social
e ci facevamo gli squilli
per risparmiare il credito.
Stiamo assistendo ad enormi rivoluzioni
scientifiche e tecnologiche.
Solo per citarne qualcuna:
pensiamo al problema
del surriscaldamento globale;
alla transizione energetica;
alla digitalizzazione;
ma anche alle intelligenze artificiali;
alla genomica;
alla blockchain.
Volenti o nolenti,
la tecnologia entrerà sempre più
a far parte delle nostre vite
e questo ci metterà di fronte
ad una serie di problemi etici e politici.
Infatti, con le nostre scelte
siamo chiamati a decidere le sorti
della nostra generazione
L’unica cosa che possiamo fare
è farci trovare pronti,
consapevoli.
Come?
Divulgando la scienza
e avendo voglia di ascoltarla.
Non facciamoci trovare impreparati,
perché il mondo ha bisogno
di questa consapevolezza.
Enormemente.
Grazie.
(Applausi)